THE PROCESS, JOINING ME NOW
TO DISCUSS THIS IS DR. CORNEL
WEST HIMSELF.
ACCLAIMED. AUTHOR
ACTIVIST AND PROFESSOR
WHO'S NOW REJOINING THE UNION
THEOLOGICAL SEMINARY IN NEW
YORK AS THE DIETRICH
BONHOEFFER
CHAIR DR. WEST THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING BACK ON THE
SHOW.
YOU
ANNOUNCED BACK IN MARCH THAT
YOU WERE ENDING
YOUR EFFORTS TO GET,
TENURED AT HARVARD AND THAT
YOU'LL BE LEAVING TO JOIN NEW.
YORK'S UNION, THEOLOGICAL
SEMINARY. SO WHY DID YOU SHARE
THIS
PRETTY
OUTSPOKEN LETTER NOW?
WELL, I WAS TOLD THAT I
HAD TO WRITE A LETTER OF
RESIGNATION BY JUNE
30TH. THAT'S WHAT I
ATTEMPTED TO DO. AND THEN I
SAID, YOU KNOW,
AS MY DEAR BROTHER PRINCE
WOULD SAY IT'S A SIGN OF THE
TIMES I DIDN'T WANT TO GO INTO
THE
NIGHT
SILENTLY. I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
TRY TO BEAR
WITNESS TO CERTAIN KINDS OF
QUEST FOR TRUTH AND GOODNESS,
AND BEAUTY AND FOR ME, AS A
CHRISTIAN TO HOLD IT. AND I
DO THINK
WE LIVE IN A TIME OF SUCH
OVERWHELMING,
SPIRITUAL DECAY
AND MORALE.
KREPLACH, TOOT, OR MORAL
CAUSES OF BEING REDUCED TO
JUST MARKET BRANDS
OR ANY QUEST FOR SPIRITUAL
EXCELLENCE AND GREATNESS
IS BEING REDUCED TO FINANCIAL
SUCCESS
AND WE'VE GOT TOO MANY
PRESSURES STUDENTS OF ALL
COLORS COMING THROUGH, WHO
NEED TO BE EXPOSED TO
RICH,
SOCRATIC, LEGACIES
OF ATHENS, AND
PROPHETIC LEGACIES OF
JERUSALEM, AND THAT
RICH TRADITIONS AND AFRICA,
MARTIN
RICH,
LEGACIES OF
OF
EXEMPLARY FIGURES IN ASIA
INDIGENOUS, PEOPLES, THE QUEST
FOR TRUTH AND GOODNESS AND
BEAUTY AND THE HOLY IS
SOMETHING THAT EVERY CULTURE,
EVERY
CIRCLES VISION
PRODUCES IN THE QUESTION IS,
HOW DO WE KEEP
ALIVE THOSE HIGH STANDARDS OF
EXCELLENCE?
EXCELLENCE, MY BROTHER?
IN YOUR LETTER, YOU
SAY
THAT IT WAS YOUR
PRO-PALESTINIAN
ACTIVIST IN YOUR
POLITICS
PRO-PALESTINIAN
WAS THE REASON WHY YOU WERE
POLITICS
REFUSED TENURE AT ONE POINT,
WAS THE REASON WHY YOU WERE
YOU CALL IT THE COWARDLY
REFUSED TENURE AT ONE POINT,
DEFERENCE TO THE ANTI
YOU CALL IT THE COWARDLY
PALESTINIAN PREJUDICES OF THE
DEFERENCE TO THE ANTI
HARVARD ADMINISTRATION, IS
PALESTINIAN PREJUDICES OF THE
THAT THE ONLY REASON YOU THINK
HARVARD ADMINISTRATION, IS
THEY DENIED YOU TENURE, AND A
THAT THE ONLY REASON YOU THINK
LOT OF YOUR CRITICS ARE
THEY DENIED YOU TENURE, AND A
SAYING, WELL, WHERE'S YOUR
LOT OF YOUR CRITICS ARE
EVIDENCE TO SHOW?
SAYING, WELL, WHERE'S YOUR
IT WAS SUPPORT FOR
EVIDENCE TO SHOW?
PALESTINIANS IT COST YOU YOUR
IT WAS SUPPORT FOR
TENURE. IT'S A BIG CLAIM.
PALESTINIANS IT COST YOU YOUR
WHAT'S THE
TENURE. IT'S A BIG CLAIM.
EVIDENCE FOR IT?
WHAT'S THE
WELL, ONE IS, THERE'S BEEN A
EVIDENCE FOR IT?
NUMBER OF CANDIDATES TO COME
WELL, ONE IS, THERE'S BEEN A
THE BEEN DENIED TENURE
NUMBER OF CANDIDATES TO COME
OWING TO THEIR DEEP SOLIDARITY
THE BEEN DENIED TENURE
WITH THE PALESTINIAN CAUSE
OWING TO THEIR DEEP SOLIDARITY
ALONGSIDE
WITH THE PALESTINIAN CAUSE
THAT SOPHISTICATED
ALONGSIDE
SCHOLARSHIP. ONE INCLUDES
THAT SOPHISTICATED
INFECTED.
SCHOLARSHIP. ONE INCLUDES
A HIGHLY ACCLAIMED
INFECTED.
JEWISH-ISRAELI SISTER SO IT'S
A HIGHLY ACCLAIMED
NOT JUST A MATTER
JEWISH-ISRAELI SISTER SO IT'S
OF EITHER BLACK OR WHITE
NOT JUST A MATTER
OR
OF EITHER BLACK OR WHITE
PALESTINIAN OR ARAB
OR
IS THOSE WHO WERE CONCERNED
PALESTINIAN OR ARAB
ABOUT TRUTH AND CONDITIONS
IS THOSE WHO WERE CONCERNED
TRUTH IS TO ALLOW SUFFERING TO
ABOUT TRUTH AND CONDITIONS
SPEAK AND CERTAINLY THE
TRUTH IS TO ALLOW SUFFERING TO
SUFFERING AMONG OUR PRECIOUS
SPEAK AND CERTAINLY THE
PALESTINIAN BROTHERS, AND
SUFFERING AMONG OUR PRECIOUS
SISTERS ARE AT
PALESTINIAN BROTHERS, AND
IS JUST BEYOND MEASURE IN
SISTERS ARE AT
TERMS OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
IS JUST BEYOND MEASURE IN
UNDER
TERMS OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
PATIENT. BUT  OCCUPATION.
UNDER
IMPACT BEYOND THAT,
PATIENT. BUT  OCCUPATION.
THOUGH THE ISSUE OF HOW TO
IMPACT BEYOND THAT,
COME TO TERMS
THOUGH THE ISSUE OF HOW TO
ISRAELI-PALESTINIAN.
COME TO TERMS
REALITIES
ISRAELI-PALESTINIAN.
DIFFICULT TO HAVE A
REALITIES
RESPECTFUL CONVERSATION,
DIFFICULT TO HAVE A
ANYBODY CRITICAL FOR THE MOST
RESPECTFUL CONVERSATION,
PART OF ISRAELI, OCCUPATION
ANYBODY CRITICAL FOR THE MOST
VIEWS ANTI-JEWISH AND
PART OF ISRAELI, OCCUPATION
ANTI-SEMITIC,
VIEWS ANTI-JEWISH AND
YOU GET DEMONIZE
ANTI-SEMITIC,
OVERNIGHT.
YOU GET DEMONIZE
AND SO, IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT
OVERNIGHT.
THOSE WHO ARE WILLING TO STEP
AND SO, IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT
OUT OR GOING TO
THOSE WHO ARE WILLING TO STEP
BE TARGETED IN A VARIETY OF
OUT OR GOING TO
DIFFERENT WAYS.
BE TARGETED IN A VARIETY OF
WAYS. I'M NOT THE
DIFFERENT WAYS.
I WANT
WAYS. I'M NOT THE
TO BE MARC, LAMONT HILL IS
I WANT
A WHOLE WAVE OF FOLK WHO
TO BE MARC, LAMONT HILL IS
HAVE EXPERIENCED IT BUT KEEP
A WHOLE WAVE OF FOLK WHO
IN MIND THIS MY BROTHER. YES,
HAVE EXPERIENCED IT BUT KEEP
THAT I AS AN ISOLATED
IN MIND THIS MY BROTHER. YES,
PERSON HERE AT
THAT I AS AN ISOLATED
HOME AND YOU KNOW, STILL VERY
PERSON HERE AT
PRIVILEGED AND VERY VERY VERY
HOME AND YOU KNOW, STILL VERY
BLESSED THAT THIS
PRIVILEGED AND VERY VERY VERY
KIND OF
BLESSED THAT THIS
DESIGN EWING AND
KIND OF
DISMISSING, IT
DESIGN EWING AND
DISRESPECTING OF BLACK PEOPLE,
DISMISSING, IT
PEOPLE OF COLOR,
DISRESPECTING OF BLACK PEOPLE,
AND THOSE WERE WILLING TO STEP
PEOPLE OF COLOR,
OUT AND BE CRITICAL OF TABOO
AND THOSE WERE WILLING TO STEP
ISSUES. IN THIS CASE, THE
OUT AND BE CRITICAL OF TABOO
PALESTINIAN CAUSE
ISSUES. IN THIS CASE, THE
THAT THAT'S HAPPENING
PALESTINIAN CAUSE
ACROSS THE BOARD.
THAT THAT'S HAPPENING
WOMAN. IT'S NOT HARD. BUT THIS
ACROSS THE BOARD.
IS
WOMAN. IT'S NOT HARD. BUT THIS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES STATE.
IS
COLLEGES
COMMUNITY COLLEGES STATE.
UNIVERSITY, INCLUDING BLACK
COLLEGES
LIKE DR. WESTLAKE
THE BLACK COLLEGE OF THE
WONDERFUL.
I'M NOT DISPUTING. OF COURSE
THAT
IT'S VERY DEMANDING ABOUT THE
SUBJECT AND THAT BAD
FACE ACTORS, THE BAD FAITH,
ACTORS
MISUSE
THE ANTI-SEMITISM CHARGE IN
THE CONTEXT OF CRITICIZING
ISRAEL, BUT IN TERMS OF YOUR
OWN EXPERIENCE YOUR CRITICS
WOULD SAY, CAN YOU NAME
SOMEONE AT HARVARD WHO
BROUGHT UP THE PALESTINE ISSUE
WITH YOU BECAUSE YOUR CRITICS
LIKE MICHAEL COHEN WHO'S
A BOSTON GLOBE COLUMNIST,
FORMER STATE DEPARTMENT, SPENT
TRYING TO, HE DID, ACCUSE YOU
OF ANTI-SEMITISM. HE SAYS, YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE SAID
TALKING ABOUT THESE.
OCCUPATION OF PALESTINE IS A
TABOO ISSUE, AMONG CERTAIN
CIRCLES IN HIGH PLACES, WHICH
IS WHAT YOU SAID IN FEBRUARY.
HE SAID, YOU'RE FEEDING INTO
AN ANTI-SEMITIC TROPE BY
SAYING THAT. CAN YOU
RESPOND TO HIM? AND CAN YOU
OFFER EVIDENCE OF SOMEONE
ACTUALLY SAYING TO, YOU KNOW
WHAT, CORNEL WEST, YOU'VE GOT
NO FUTURE HERE BECAUSE OF YOUR
PAST PRO-PALESTINIAN POLITICS.
WELL, ONE ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO
DO SERIOUS RESEARCH
IN, GO INTO THE
HARGETT AT HARVARD ARCHIVES,
AND COME UP WITH
THEIR REJECTION OF THREE
HIGH
QUALITY.
PROFESSORS.
ALL THREE OF WHOM WERE
DEEPLY, CRITICAL OF ISRAELI
OCCUPATION,
BUT WOULD BE IN FACT
ACCEPTABLE, BASED ON ACADEMIC
CRITERIA
IN MY CASE IT COULDN'T BE
ACADEMIC CRITERIA WAS
UNIVERSITY PROFESSOR AT
PRINCETON AS WELL AS HARVARD
IT COULD BE A MATTER OF AGE,
BUT IF THAT WERE THE CASE,
DIDN'T AGEISM IS OPERATING.
AND SO, I DON'T THINK IT'S
THAT. SO IT HAS TO BE
POLITICAL WHAT OTHER
CANDIDATES WOULD IT BE IN MY
CASE, MY DEAR
IN SOLIDARITY WITH BERNICE?
AND HE WAS SUPPORTED
WHY SIDE
I THINK THAT WOULD BE
A STRONG ENOUGH
ISSUE THAT WOULD LEAD FOR THEM
TO BE. SO FEARFUL OF
JUST ALLOWING ME TO GO THROUGH
A
10-YEAR PROCESS AFTER
RECEIVING TENURE AT YALE.
AND UNIVERSITY PROFESSORS
TWICE
AND 96 AND
2000 TO WHAT OTHER REASON
COULD DO I HAVE? IT WOULD BE
NICE. IF THE HARVARD
ADMINISTRATION, THE HARVARD
PRESIDENT
WERE TO LAY OUT WHAT THE
ARGUMENT IS. LET'S HEAR WHAT
IT IS. YEAH. IT'S
IT'S INTERESTING THAT
IT'S INTERESTING
THAT HARVARD HAVE NOT OFFERED
ANY REAL
SUBSTANTIVE RESPONSE TO YOUR
ACCUSATION. SO WE'LL WAIT AND
SEE
WE'LL WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS
THERE. BUT STEPPING BACK FOR A
SECOND TO SOMEONE IN ACADEMIA.
CAN YOU PUT INTO CONTEXT?
WHAT'S GOING ON ON
AMERICAN CAMPUSES RIGHT NOW?
BECAUSE ON THE ONE HAND,
YOU HEAR FROM THE RIGHT?
THAT'S COOL. BEDS ARE HOTBEDS
SCHOOLS. ARE HOTBEDS FOR
LIBERAL INDOCTRINATION.
LEFTIES, ARE SNOWFLAKES,
LIBERALS, WANT TO CANCEL
EVERYTHING
AND THEN YOU SEE PEOPLE LIKE
NICOLE, HANNAH JONES BEING
DENIED TENURE, YOU SEE THE
BANNING OF CRITICAL RACE
THEORY?
YOU SEE WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
YOUR SELF-DESCRIBED TOOLS,
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN AMERICAN
UNIVERSITIES RIGHT NOW
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
TREATMENT, THE TREATMENT OF
MIND NECESSITY FOR HAD A JONES
BUSINESS PICKLE,
AND I'M GLAD TO SEE SHE AND
BROTHER
COLTS MAKING THEIR WAY TO
HOWARD HOWARD, THE GREAT
GREAT INSTITUTION, AND IT'S
GOING TO HAVE ITS OWN
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF
INTERNAL STRUGGLES
UNIONIZATION OF HIS
ADJUNCT PROFESSORS THE ENVY
AND RESENTMENT. THAT IS TRUE
CONTEXTS INCLUDING UNIVERSITY
BUT THE PROBLEM IS THIS MY
BROTHER THAT
THERE'S A
MARKET DRIVEN
QUALITY, THE EVERY INSTITUTION
IN AMERICA. SO THE UNITED
THE UNIVERSITIES ARE HAVE
BECOME SO
COMMODIFIED.
THEY ARE BARACK
WITH TIES AND TOP
HEAVY.
SO THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
MONEY
RELATION OF DONORS AND
BENEFACTORS. ON THE ONE HAND,
AND AT THE SAME TIME, THEY'VE
GOT BUREAUCRATS AT THE TOP
THAT ARE OBSESSED WITH
DIVERSITY, BUT THE SHADOW OF
JIM CROW,
THE LEGACY OF WHITE SUPREMACY
STEEL-CUT, VERY BEAT, BUT IN A
VERY, VERY SUBTLE
MANNER,
BUT A LOT
ABOUT DIVERSITY AND EQUITY AND
INCLUSION, AND SO FORTH AND SO
ON. BUT WHEN YOU ACTUALLY LOOK
AT THE STRUCTURES AND THE
INSTITUTIONS OF THE PLACE,
EVEN WHEN
IT'S MORE
COLORFUL A
AT THE TOP WITH
BLACKS AND WHITES AND
ASIANS AND SO FORTH.
TRANSLATED ON THE GROUND
AND TRANSLATOR ON THE GROUND,
MAKES NOT JUST THE IMPACT ON
STUDENTS, BUT ON THE
PERCENTAGE OF
DIFFERENT GROUPS
REPRESENTED ACROSS THE
BOARD, NOT ALL OF THEM IN
AFRICA IS THAT IS ALL
AMANDA CERTAIN STUDY, BUT
ACROSS THE BOARD, YOU
STILL SEE SHADOWS OF JIM CROW.
SO YOU GET THIS
MIXTURE AND IT'S REALLY IN
SOME WAYS.
A LETHAL MIXTURE OF
COMMODIFICATION
MARKET-DRIVEN, THIS OBSESSION
WITH MONEY STATUS
RANKINGS. AND ON THE OTHER
HAND, THE INABILITY
OF DIVERSITY TO COME TO TERMS
OF WHAT IS MOST IMPORTANT,
WHICH IS THE QUEST FOR
TRUTH.
GOODNESS,
BEAUTY, AND SOME SENSE WITH
THE HOLY IF YOU'RE RELIGIOUS
LIKE MYSELF, THAT'S WHAT
UNIVERSITY SHOULD BE ABOUT
6 AWAY AGAINST
THREE, A
TRADITION. IF BHAKRA SEE,
BEER,
THE FREEING UP OF ALL OF US
TO ENGAGE IN SERIOUS
QUEST. SOME
DR. WEST, LET ME LET ME JUMP
IN BEFORE YOU RUN OUT OF TIME
IN TERMS OF THE QUEST FOR
TRUTH, WE'RE SEEING A BATTLE
AGAINST A BIG LIE IN AMERICA.
WE'RE SEEING A BATTLE AGAINST
VOTING RIGHTS FROM THE
REPUBLICANS
EARLIER TODAY, MORE THAN
A HUNDRED FIFTY COMPANIES FROM
PEPSICO TO AMAZON TO TARGET
ISSUED A LETTER VOICING THEIR
SUPPORT FOR VOTING RIGHTS.
YOU HAVE JOE BIDEN
GIVING HIS BIG SPEECH
YESTERDAY
TALKING ABOUT
DEMOCRACY VERSUS AUTOCRACY.
HAVE A
LISTEN.
FIRST, ASK THOSE WHO REPRESENT
US AT THE FEDERAL STATE LOCAL
LEVELS.
WILL YOU DENY
THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE? WILL YOU IGNORE THEIR
VOICES?
WE HAVE TO ASK,
ARE YOU ON THE SIDE OF TRUTH
OR
LIES
FACTOR FIXING JUST A TRUE
INJUSTICE.
INJUSTICE?
DEMOCRACY ARE OUR TOC RECEI.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S COMING DOWN
TO.
DO YOU AGREE? DR.
WESTON IS DEMOCRACY VERSUS
AUTOCRACY AND IF SO IS JOE
BIDEN UP TO THE FIGHT?
WELL I HOPE HE IS IF NOT WE'VE
GOT TO BE AS A
GROUP OF CITIZENS WILLING TO
ENGAGE IN COLLECTIVE ACTION TO
PRESERVE THE BEST DEMOCRATIC
PROJECT. BUT NO, THE UNITED
STATES IS VERY OLD
OLEG, ARCHICAD POINT.
IT'S HARD TO CALL US IN ANY
WAY. A SUBSTITUTE OF
DEMOCRACY TO BITING HIMSELF
AND BEEN SO
TIRED THE CORPORATE ELITE SO
TIED TO WALL STREET SO TIED TO
AN OLD
GUARD IN AMERICA.
NOW WHEN HE
EQUALS AUTOCRACY. I WOULD CALL
AUTHORITARIAN, I WOULD CALL
ESCALATING
FASCISM THE NEO-FASCISM BOTH.
AROUND THE WORLD AS WELL AS
INSIDE THE UNITED STATES WITH
TRUMP AND COMPANY.
SO THAT I THINK
THERE'S JUST
DEMOCRATIC ASPECTS OF
OLIGARCHIC AMERICA, BUT WE'RE
IN A MUCH MUCH DIMMER.
MOMENT THAN WHAT HE'S
PROJECTING. AND NOTICE HE